five important points and all the pi
points
are verified first there is cover
up in china about such curvature
outbreak
there is already human to human
transmission
this is a highly mutant virus there is
no intermediate
host the wu hong kong seafood market is
just a smoke
screen from chinese government this
virus
is not from nature it is a map modified
what gives you this level of certainty
to say you know because you're saying
i know for a fact this is man-made how
do you know
more than my scientific evidence i
present in this report and also the next
one this is a very important matter the
world stopped for six months
million people have died because it is
if this is man-made
they need to be held accountable and if
you based on your research that you're
making you're not right
i think we also need to know that you
were wrong in certain places quite
frankly don't trust both sides 100
so together with all these things i
think it's easy for people to understand
who is my if what you say
is true this could be the biggest
cover-up of this century
[Music]
so my guest today is dr lee mangian who
uh recently was interviewed on the
tucker carlson show
and in the span of five days her
interview five minute clip got nearly
three million views
and it created a lot of havoc because
she's been on a couple interviews in the
past before
but she's a defector from china who made
claims that says the coronavirus
covenant 19
is not uh through bats it's actually
man-made and it was made intentionally
and she's made those claims she wrote a
paper about it
there are some folks that are not happy
about it national geographic wrote a
uh paper about it on september 18 saying
why misinformation about kobe 19's
origins
keeps going viral daily beasts talked
about steve bannon is behind bogus study
that china created kovit
and we're gonna cover that stuff as well
but a couple things you need to know
about her
uh her background she left uh april 28
of 2020
she came to new york april 29 2020. we
don't know her locations we are not
disclosed in any location
uh she is uh not very uh
uh comfortable about her safety right
now as we go through this interview
she went to university and got her md
from zhang medical college of central
south university
she got her phd from smu southern
medical university known as first
military medical academy and she was
doing a research um
at university of hong kong a very very
interesting story and by the way one
thing everybody needs to know is a lot
of times when i do these interviews
i think it's important for the audience
to know is there anything being paid to
her we're not paying her anything
she didn't ask for money there is no
additional way of compensating her
she's not selling a book so a lot of
times i get a red flag when somebody is
trying to sell a book
and i hope youtube allows this interview
to stay on
as a fair interview where others can
make a decision for themselves
about what she has to say so having said
that uh dr
lee ming yang thank you so much for
being a guest on valuetainment hi
patrick thank you for having me yes
anytime
and and look uh obviously with the
current situation you're in yourself i
think the first question i want to ask
is before we get into a lot of uh
these uh claims and papers you've
written is you know uh
i left iran and i went to germany and
i'm from germany i came here i lived in
iran for 10
years and then i lived in germany at
refugee camp for two years
i have my own reasons why i left iran my
family and i left iran
and came to the states you are seen as a
defector a defector in somebody that
abandons their own country for another
one why did you abandon china and come
to the u.s
okay so first uh i just want to ask i
didn't hear you kadiana did you mention
my phd got from central south medical
university
is a formal military university right
because when i was there i'm not the one
in the army and that was not the
military university
just to stress it because someone tried
to miss disease
i think that's very important for
everybody you know meaning you've never
been part of the ccp it's very good
yeah so the reason i have to leave china
actually is very very realistic
because i was assigned to the secret
investigation representative of who
reference lab in the university of hong
kong school public health
and at that time my supervisor professor
diopong
who is a who consultant an emerging
disease
who asked me to do this investigation
for the
unknown pneumonia happened in wuhan
at the end of december 31 december 2019
so at that time make of information from
china government to even hong kong and
also
overseas and then after the
investigations
because i got my md phd from mainland as
you stressed
and i have my very unique but vast
that kind of network from chinese
hospitals
authorities including cdc and also
different institutes including the
military ones
and another thing is i'm the only one in
that core team
who can speak in mandarin and also have
the
two degrees so that means i can
communicate well and fully
understand those information so since i
was assigned to do this work as
i already mentioned in other media that
i got the fact from china and
responded to professor leopon and
also professor martin perez who is a
co-head of the whole map
and the top chronovirus expert top 1 in
the world
they both know the things but they
choose to keep silence
and collaborate with chinese communist
party and
also i get warned that be careful
don't cross the red line if not you will
be in trouble and you will be
despaired and they want me to keep
silence
too so together with all the information
i stressed before that
all the things make me cannot keep
silent
because it's urgent time so 19th
january i have to go
through a media that based in
youtube it's called the modus broadcast
it's a chinese blogger
who is in us to deliver the message
anti-chinese communist party with the
truth
so i didn't know him before but i trust
him and he's the only one i can trust at
that time
to deliver the truth so making
i contact him and hey respond to me i
spent two days from 17 january to 19th
january
to explain all the things i can tell him
and let him
understand the situation and then he
delivers a message
out at night in beijing time 19th
january
which includes five important points
and all the pythons are verified
these five pounds are first there is
cover up
in china about the south korea to
outbreak
cover up including the how they
use the wrong case number and also they
claim that
is no medical stuff infected and
other things many other things and the
other the second
one is there already human to human
transmission
exists the surfacing is
this is a high mutant virus
and if no stop no control immediately
there would be a big outbreak in china
and
even worse remember that time only 62
cases in the
world so without intelligence and
enough knowledge i cannot tell such
words
and the first thing is there is no
intermediate
host no wild animal as host
the wu hong hwan seafood market is just
a smoke
screen from chinese government and the
fifth thing is this virus is not from
nature
it is a map modified virus based on the
chinese military
map discovered and owned the joshua
bad chronovirus cc45
and dxc21 and
from that they become a harmful diesel
virus so all these five things now can
be verified
and just within hours we delivered this
message out
the china government realized there is
someone who really knows a
fact inside so they quickly have respond
to that
including within four hours they update
the case number
from 62 to 198
that was midnight in china and the next
morning
they admit that there are more cases
out of wuhan in shanghai in guangdong
and again in the afternoon they admit
human to human transmission exists also
chairman xi issued the first statement
in 2020 which pulled the suspect to
infectious disease from the common
things to the
south male in the home as a highly
infectious disease and has to be
monitored
and again three days later they knocked
down wuhan
but somehow they still met people go
around the world from
wuhan which is very very terrible
and from that time i start to work with
mr mood
because i again and again realize there
are more things chinese communist party
won't
cover up including they
try to hold the ppe from all over the
world
but even not give the doctors in wuhan
who is on the
front line to fight with the disease
can you believe that i mean they hold
all the things in the
red cross storage but not allow the
wuhan medical staff to get hit
and uh medical staffs are very pity
they ask for help online through the
friends
and government as them to servant
and other thing including like doctor
johnny is a bad woman the famous one
since the 19th general within your
message
the next day she quickly submits a very
famous
nature paper now which is a founding
evidence for nature origin of south
korea too
they 20 january they submit the paper
with the iatg-13 virus
to nature journal and the third february
nature publish aid the same day another
paper was published from
shanghai that team said joshenbatvirus
actually was the closest
one to this south korea which can be the
origin
and that team get punished their p3 map
is shut down by the government
and xi jingles iatj 13 virus
although it's pro problematic
and amount of research scientists
challenge the data the quality different
aspects
and also from intelligence i can tell
you they never have such virus
collected so basically this is
fabricated virus
but then that becomes the fundamental
evidence
which is supported by the scientific
word
to say this virus comes from nature
and based on this they developed many
many
other publications and also apply it to
different aspects related to sasquatu
investigation and also later most things
i can stress later with you like
including to the
antibody screening including to the
asymptomatic things
all this but until end of april
i got the intelligence from mr mood that
chinese communist party already realized
i'm the one delivered to choose out
so i will be the one they make
disappeared soon and also i realized
that
chinese speaking country and the english
speaking world are totally different
also our message saved millions of
chinese people and our audience
feedback to us thank to us but english
countries overseas
people suffer this pandemic and chinese
communist party
who their first method go
so i want to deliver the message to the
english speaking country too
and if i stand up in hong kong as you
can understand now
immediately before my message delivered
out i will be
killed so for these two reasons
i decided to leave hong kong and
the zhu of rao foundation which is a
foundation
to help the people anti-chinese
communist party
to reveal the truth they helped me to
escape from hong kong
so that's the reason i came to us
did you say the zhuang gyar foundation
is this the gentleman who's a
billionaire
a very successful individual is that the
entrepreneur
yeah the rule of foundation related
to the miles school and mr berner
but this is not the reason that they
should get
attacked in the media because
for people like me this is the only
i mean reliable way to help me go out
and also to help me speak out to the
world and they really
helped me i i don't understand
why people attack me because of
jew or small foundation this foundation
is from people who support the
anti-chinese communist
party activities and donate their money
to the foundation
to help people like me without this
foundation's support
i will be already despair in china and
no one
get child to know the truth and to know
the report and my
later statement that's that's so so i
you know that's a whole different story
with him maybe we'll get into him here
in a minute because i
got his own youtube channel and he is uh
not a big fan of china and he's not
staying quiet about it but let me go
back to what you said about your five
points
on why you left and you eventually came
to the states so
the last thing you said you know you
said the virus
is not uh naturals not from nature right
it is man-made is what you're saying and
the way you're saying it you're saying
it with a level of certainty you're not
saying
uh uh potentially maybe
it could be possibly you know we need to
find a
the way you're saying this it is it is a
very strong statement that you make so
it brings three different questions for
me
and i'll go through them with this first
so you said at that moment they went
from 62 cases
that they announced to 198 and
immediately won by one by one they
addressed the right issues
if i go online right now to get the
cases china states that right now total
they have 85
291 cases total ever of coronavirus and
only 4
634 people have died number one before i
go to my next question how much do
you trust the data that china gives to
the public
so it means hotel that's too right i can
tell you that chinese government itself
won't
believe that and it's a real number
maybe we never know
for example i can tell you how they
count the numbers
like from the beginning my first hand
information told me that
so from the beginning the way they delay
the cases
is to postpone the diagnosis which you
cannot do it in hospital
already it's a highly suspicious patient
which ruled
out other pathogens and the government
said
they do the diagnosis not the hospital
and then they delay the result so this
is
one way the other way is they give very
limited
kids to the hospital which cannot give
enough patients for diagnosis
and then they use a markdown to keep
people
at home and don't allow them to go to
hospital without permission
and the other thing is when the people
that
in the hospital if it's according to the
us way for example we i i did the
influenza research
before for several years so for
influenza patients
once you get influenza diagnosed and
later you die of the
conditions or you have already have the
fundamental disease but this triggered
you
and then the guy passed away counted as
influenza
they leave to death right but in china
no
so they will give you the test for twice
and they give you the ventilator machine
once you get
you know go to the icu they tried their
best to promote your
life and once they found oh two times
negative from your throat
so you are the one die of some other
reason
hard reason one reason whatever reason
not from kobe 19. and the chinese way to
test
it is not the way we are using in other
countries even not the way we are using
in hong kong
those ones can reach to 90 to 95 percent
accuracy but the way in china in
mainland
government among those different
protocols
only have 20 to 30 percent accuracy
they admitted the new aid but
remember for twice test
and then you gather as a positive or
negative
this cannot be covered by the 20 to 30
percent accuracy
you use such quantity of the way to test
people
you have to do like non-time or your
environment time
to gather real results so this
is another way that the
real cases are ignored
so so let me ask you let me go back to
that question let me go back to that
question the way you broke it down 20 to
accuracy so when we in america
we don't know what's going on in china
because we don't have nbc fox cnn bbc
social media we don't have nothing in
china
so a lot of the u.s media just reports
what china gives us and we don't have a
freedom of press in china to know here's
what's going on
exactly when we go on google which is
what presses to america when we want to
get our data
if you go on google and you type in u.s
china
u.s has 328 million people living here
that's our population
china has 1.393 billion people living
there right
u.s has 6.86 million cases
okay of course 19. china has only 85 000
cases
of kobe 19. u.s has 202 000
people that have died in the u.s china
only has 4
634 people that have died in the u.s
so what you're saying is that china has
a lot more because as for for somebody
that's you
it almost seems like in the u.s the
numbers are reported bigger than it
really is
and the numbers in china are almost
being reported smaller than what they
are
what would you say to that so i won't
say is i don't have the
first hand information and i can let you
know that china government tried their
best
to show people that this is not big deal
in china
so this is something they can control
very well as also they mentioned they
have the so-called
successful vaccine and they have zero
cases
and even from the like april to may they
start to claim that
oh the new cases are all imported from
other countries
and what else china government have
stressed they also said
these virus come from u.s origin from
u.s and also they evil ones dress it to
some
except for the poor animals they won't
tell you it could from outer space
so together with all these things i
think it's easy for people to understand
who is smiling and why can you trust
their desktop number and the situation
about kobe 19.
so you don't trust any data that china
gives about the number of cases i've
been
in china for over 30 years i grew up
from
this whole system and i have so many
contacts there i mean
uh relationships there master network
all these things together i can tell you
don't trust it
and you're laughing it's you almost like
laughing at americans that we believe
those numbers that's what
because in china in u.s people thought
that everyone can tell the truth so if
there is something like that at least
you can
hear from someone or from some media
although maybe it's now the mainstream
you still can hear from other voice but
in china
and even now i think china u.s people
can understand
chinese communist party is so powerful
in controlling your voice your thinking
so they have their propaganda and they
have their
very strict structure and strategy to
affect these things
for example in my case i'm the one who
want to tell the fact tell the truth
based on scientific evidence and
intelligence
but since i start to tell things they
try to make me depart
and since i go to u.s even before i
exposed in public in july from fox news
chinese communist party sends the
placements
from hong kong to beijing and the
ministry of state security
send people to my hometown qingdao
immediately when i steal
on the flight to question my family
and to push them collaborate with them
to bring me back
and also the hong kong government there
are
dozens of policemen take in charge of my
case
and the placement team placement at
least
search my very small apartment in hong
kong which is only
200 square inches
very small one uh yeah you know the hong
kong living
situation and then the university of
hong kong
vice chancellor approved zhang jiang who
is actually
back from us his academic
uh fellowship in the engineering field
in u.s
who at the same night i smile away
call for the alumni and staff in the
university of
hong kong immediately collect all the
information about me
and search me and some informer
from my school alumni tells us we chat
all my friends even middle school friend
or university friend
that slimming yin now is in a criminal
cases everyone has to report to
placement about information related to
her
even in the past half years she has no
privacy now
everyone has to be responsible for the
things if you hide
any information all together is the
enzymes of china recruit the cyber
military umau
those people to attack me online on
twitter on facebook they establish
many fake accounts using my profile
my name and try to spread the
misinformation
represent of me and since
i tell the truth and publish my report
last week
my twitter account immediately got
shut down by twitter without any reason
another interesting i can tell you you
know what i have
another anonymous account which i
use just to share some information no
one knows that's me
just because i share the same phone log
in the two accounts
that small account is shut down at the
same time
and facebook labeled me as fake news but
at the same time they amount of the
fake demonian account arrived spreading
the mis
information even thousands of people try
to complain
no response from them yeah you know
that's a
by the way 200 inches i'm sure you were
trying to say 200 feet because 200
inches
my shoe yeah sorry 200 inches is like
this big i'm sure you're talking about
200 feet because yeah sorry standing up
it's kind of weird
with that so okay so facebook
and uh twitter i'm always curious to
know why they're defending uh
uh china and they're so worried about
protecting china but we'll get past that
because i know both your video was taken
down
on facebook and instagram of tuckers and
uh your twitter was suspended without
any explanation so
first point is you don't trust any data
great check let's go to the next one
for you to say this with a level of
certainty that you're saying it you're
not saying it with any hesitation you're
not saying it with any doubt
you're saying it with certainty i
believe in god
but i can't say i 100 believe god exists
factual because i haven't met him it's
faith i
believe you know faith is believing in
something you have not yet seen
right that's faith that's why we say i
believe right
you're not saying i believe you're
saying you know this is man
made what gives you this level of
certainty to say you know because
when you say you know you're not leaving
anything
for somebody to come and uh you know
make an argument because you're just
saying you know so you're getting so
many targets at you
because you're saying i know for a fact
this is man-made how do you know
so briefly what i can tell you is there
is
only one truth for these curving 19
things
and the truth is it is now the nature
origin
jump from bad directly to human and
i say i know because more than my
scientific evidence i present
in this report and also the next one
which will come out soon
i also have intelligence and information
and also i know deeply about this
chinese communist party and because of
my special position
in that core map in hong kong
i know those kind of top uh
biologists in this world i know
i stayed with them for several for many
years i mean actually i was in hong kong
for eight years and
i know this some of these people like
professor malik paris
and not late uh just i mean several
months later since i go to hong kong
and also i can tell you uh my husband
who is also a core scientist work in the
same lab
he is the most trustful helper
for professor manik paris and both of
them
from sri lanka and this is a
very specific bridge for me
to get more familiar with malik and
also know more about these things i
cannot tell
too much in the media at this moment but
i
already get contacted by the u.s
government the relevant people
and based on all these intelligent
things
and my scientific evidence and the fact
i got from china during the kobe 19
get gathered all the things clearly can
tell people
this is from the lab and this
is the things intentionally released
from the map okay so so i'm going to
come back to what organizations
contacted you because i do want to ask
you that
uh who you had the interview with maybe
we can talk about that here in a minute
but let me stay on this topic here
so while you're saying this i go online
and i research
how many total virologists we have in
america because i'm just curious when
you're saying a number like that
i want to see what this data comes out
it tells me
in america today uh virology
there are 19 total degrees uh different
kind of degrees you can get into that
virology
uh there is the average salary is 108
000 of your income
total people workforce 2.73 million
people
uh average employee of a virology in
that industry 41 and a half
i don't know how many virologists there
are in america but i would assume there
are many
and there are many intelligent people in
this space many doctors
many people who in america are
comfortable going against
because this is a freedom of speech
country this is not a
if you don't we're gonna do execution if
you don't we're gonna do this to you if
you don't we're gonna
you're gonna be a defector from america
we don't have a lot of defectors from
america because nobody leaves america
everybody comes over here
defectors come over here so why is it
that
you're the only one that's so public
about it saying man made
and if there are other people that are
on your side who are those people in
america that have credibility as a
doctor
not i'm a i'm a person that's got a
youtube channel you know
steve bannon may be somebody that works
on trump's campaign so a lot of people
he just got you know the whole
scandal that he had so a lot of the
public may not trust what's coming out
of his mouth
unless if it's people on his side right
you're this billionaire
q when you that escapes china and comes
here there's a lot of weird things that
said about him on a vice interview
so why is it that you are the one
who knows this is man-made and all these
other experts
who have many many years of experience
are disagreeing with you
okay first let me stress that
what i can tell you is i cannot leave
the name
for the re for some reason but i can
tell you first when i just
arrived los angeles airport to transfer
to
new york on 28 april uh
fbi stopped me the custom stopped me
and then the fbi when they heard i'm
coming here to tell the truth of kobe
19.
they told me trust but verify
and i work with them because i have like
eight hours for
transferring in that airport so i worked
with
the customer officers and later fbi
to talk about the story and after that
fbi trust me and also homeland people
came out
they heard about that and they protect
me to go to the flight
to go to checking they hold my cell
phone at that time because there are
some evidence
in my cell phone they need to make the
backup
and they promised me to give it back two
days later and two days later the fbi
agent
from los angeles airport flied to us
aside to new york
and gave my phone back to me face to
face
with new york fbi agent and
after talking new york fbi agent
arranged
the top uh biologists or biologists from
fbi the very senior one
talked to me for whole day about the
i've made this um how to explain it
yeah so see how verified my things and
that all happened
in the first few weeks when i arrived to
us
and later when i have my report between
the
during april 2 i published my report
actually there are top experts the
senior people
relevant people in the u.s government
already know this
and we talked and they read my report
so that's why although there is no peer
review
but all the feedbacks dramatic positive
support me and these are the people
people back to me to support this
evidence
also uh the whole scientific field
kept silent but you see i even this out
how do they do it what can they do
to make it and what material they are
using to make it
i also reconstruct the procedure for
most proper way they can make this virus
in the lab within 6 months
using their unique josh and bad
chronovirus as backbone
until now did you see the people i list
in my report come out to argue with me
in scientific work i mean at least
clearly that
if you check the reference over 100
records
they show you it's like treasure map you
know who has done
it and who themselves published to tell
you this part i'm the expert
i have been done that for decades i am
the one who are using this technique but
somehow do
evidence in the genome this biologist
this biologist now i can tell the name
you
check my first b part we have this did
that woman
xi jingling we have listed uh
dr lee fung in the university of
minnesota
and we have listed their collaborators
also my professor malik paris
who said immediately when i left hong
kong although he has millions of
millions of funding and
he decided to work for another five to
ten years in the university of hong kong
immediately return all these people why
don't they come out
to sue me to argue with me using
scientific way
but the chinese communist party using
their way to
suppress my report i know this is also
we try our best
uh write it in a plain way to make the
common people can understand what
happened
still i mean it's a little bit difficult
for many readers to really understand
the meaning
then what i say is like in the
geographic national geographic that
journal
the scientists who know has a
strong correlation with chinese
communist party
and also support the nature origin
theory
come out to use lies and the
misinformation
to miss these readers i have asked
some my team member because i know the
twitter account now
my team member has helped me to post
some
in english explanation online also
under the twitter of national geographic
we point out all the mice they cannot
argue with us
based on the scientific things but they
can change the world for example
if i say there is a knife some people
get killed
in the home next to him there is a knife
very specific sheep
and also the knife has blood on that and
we know
this knife only belong to the neighbor
this is evidence
but they explain it as everyone has
knife
so knife means nothing do you understand
the difference here no i i get that but
what i'm trying to say to you i mean
look when you i've looked at the
national geographic we'll get into that
here in a minute when you came over here
you know they asked the chinese embassy
about yourself they said they don't know
who you are they've never heard of this
person before meaning you
uh over here but and then you're making
these claims that this
is for a fact man made which by the way
let's just say it is man-made it would
make
it would make life in america a lot
easier because then all would happen is
they would go face the tribunal
funeral court and china would be
trillions of dollars of reparation it
can be proven
but if it can be proven but the question
i have is
you're saying you know so why don't you
unpack i know on tucker you talked about
the fingerprints how just like you have
a fingerprint can you
unpack that and explain that for a
second okay so basically
the finger uh we have the very unique
fingerprint which can identify you right
so the virus we can simply understand
the genome
as a fingerprint so based on this one
you don't say that we use some parameter
which has
may have different definition
definitions that different people have
different
understanding no this is just like
fingerprints the summit one
so the people can recognize the virus
genome
and to say oh this is this viral that is
that virus and
also the way we know which virus
involved from some other virus also
based on the genome analysis
and this is just like for the
susquehanna virus this is just
30 000 meters you can call it matter
it's a
nucleotide and so based on this
what i can tell you is this clearly
shows that
it comes from bad kernel virus the
joshian bad corner virus
discovered by military in china and also
the unusual character in the virus
which leads to the very unusual
a harmful result when they attack
human so these things
also you can see from the genome and
it's like for example they equip two
functional path which was already shown
in sas
and also in other diesel viruses like
ebola high pathogen even flu
they equip these two parts into
one section might it like human very
much
without any uh hesitation they just
bound to humans
receptor and also they need the kind of
uh you can see this is like um
this is definitely everything uh in the
in the genome it shows that
how they cut paste it from the other
thing
to this genome and also
you can see there are very very a
specific
identity between the e protein
to the bad chronovirus which means they
are totally
hundred percent the same and it never
happened in the
other similar uh this kind of
cross-species
virus so all these things together with
other things
you can see it's like you check the
fingerprint and you see the evidence of
copy paste and you see it come from
others and these copy pastes are
meaningful
to make it harmful and who has done it
those group of people on the chinese
communist party control and they are the
experts
they have working for decades as i
mentioned in the reference
list they just focused on this and they
own the biggest
virus bank in this field they are
spending years to collecting these
viruses
all over china all together and i'm the
one working on vaccine development
i have my patent for the universal
influenza vaccine on pending
but what i can tell you all this change
is not for the
medical purpose of vaccine development
at home
another way you can understand it is
like
you want to give a toy gun for your cake
but you have to remove the bullet and
also you want to change it to plastic
not the steel one
but this one is like you said i want to
make toy for my kid
and then you keep the whole gum and you
add
a sharp knife you put one more miso
and you give your kids oh this is your
toy somehow
yeah it's not safe but good purpose how
could you believe
that yeah so my follow-up question to
you on that would be who in the world
is qualified certified trained
educated enough to be able to identify
the fingerprints like you describe the
genomes to understand that this is
man-made what people in the world
uh people have why need to be able to do
this
i think this actually if they really
want to understand these things
the people who have bio uh biology or
medical degrees
they can read more things and they can
check online
and even for the smart students in u.s
like the middle school kids i think the
way they are doing
searching online can also help them to
understand this
report and also i have another report
coming out soon to help them understand
more about
the relevant situation in this case
in a scientific way and the
one thing is you said there is no other
people come out to support me
but i do get support by the
contact me directly or put retirement
in my academic profile research guide of
this
report and also we know many people
because you know this academic field is
actually a very small group
and people usually focus on their own
specific field and don't want this term
to the other field
so in this case if the top
biologists or famous chronic biologists
especially i told you the ones who work
with me work in china they are the top
people so they see we have the theory
already
and then they have the enough power
together with the chinese communist
party
and wh so all these people to influence
this academic field and later there are
more benefits for example
when they publish the nature theory like
bad woman in february there are problems
but later more funding come out
to the researchers based on the nation
nature theory
and they use the funding to do this
further investigation see
it's very very difficult for them now to
admit that
actually the fundamental theory is wrong
because that will give them trouble to
their
investigation and their reputation and
also chinese government from the early
beginning want people to solve
the animal is a host this comes from the
nature to human and i can tell you
another fact which i didn't tell in
u.s media before because i have no time
that
just in 16 yeah 16 january this year
when my supervisor leopold page has no
much
information about china's uh clover 19
situation
but he asked me to focus on one type
of the animal called raccoon dog
so he showed me that picture from email
someone
faces information to him that go to
trace this animal
see whether huh people eat this thing
and uh it's like you won't get evidence
but i'm chinese people and i this
investigation
they think chinese people doesn't like
it maybe someone ate but it's never been
a popular one or something specific in
wuhan or whatever
and there is no evidence show that
any animal dna or animal residue left
in any sample in wuhan because
all the sample in the seafood market was
cleaned and only 33
samples from invitement was collected
by chinese communist party before first
january
to show the word that these are the
environmental sample and
only one water sample shows
positive for south korea too that means
no animal evidence from any sample
in wuhan but china government and also
some people say one later further
investigation
just target to the intermediate host and
the requiem dog is like the suspicious
target like the civic in such one before
provided to some researchers
so that's uh that's interesting you're
sharing that but for me it goes back to
the same thing it goes back to
this needs to be somebody i said i asked
the question from you
who uh what expertise does somebody need
to have a certification or training or
degree to be able to do the kind of
research you do to find out that this is
man-made you said biology
medical degree so anybody that has a
degree in biology or virology
can go get access to coronavirus
someone has it look at the virus and see
it on the inside
based on whatever kind of method that
doctors use to find out that it's
man-made anybody can do that
they have to make effort in reading the
articles
and then they need to understand the
things behind that
but that's not very difficult because i
have seen that
people message online or post on twitter
that they read it
they have the bio engineer background or
they have the molecular background
and they can understand and also
let me come back on that so let me ask
you this question so for example here's
you wrote your paper and national
geographic comes out and says why
misinformation about covenant origins
keeps going viral
twitter firestone promptly erupted
prominent virologists such as christian
anderson
from scripps research and carl bergstrom
from university of washington took to
the internet and called out the paper
for being unscientific chief among their
complaints
was that the report ignored the vast
body of published literature regarding
what is known about how chronovirus
circulate
in wild animal populations and tendency
to spill over into humans including
recent publications
about the origins of stars kovat 19. the
experts have pointed out that the report
uh whipped up wild conspiracy theories
and wrongly accused academic journals of
plotting
with conspiracies and censoring
important evidence and on top of that
angela rasmussen from columbia
university
said i'm going to scream if i have to
explain the fact that many viruses
have cleavage sites uh uh cleavage sites
these are otherwise they missed the
information
that is a question to you i'm going to
come to a question to you yeah it looks
legitimate because they
use a lot of technical jargon but in
reality a lot of what they're saying
doesn't really make any sense
says rasmussen she has that the type of
cloning that uses restriction enzymes
and the out they
is is very outdated and so it's unlikely
to be used to make a viral bio weapon
and on a basic level making an
engineered virus is not a trivial matter
scientists are still
uh just trying to understand the
molecular and genetic
reasons why some viruses are more
infectious than others anyways [ __ ]
continues right but this is where i'm
going with this here's where i'm going
with this
i think it's fair to say this is a very
important matter yes
we have seven and a half billion people
nearly eight billion people
this country named china has 1.393
billion people they have eighty five
thousand cases
only forty six hundred people have died
they post a picture
saying in wuhan a water party was put
together with concerts and people are
right everything's back to normal
would you be comfortable would you be
able to if you're in the same
lab with rasmussen with
uh uh these other folks kristin anderson
with carl bergstrom
with any of these other jonathan
eisenhower or
you know would you be comfortable would
you be able to go in a lab
and show them exactly how you're able to
prove
that this is man-made not uh
just through animals would you be able
to get in it with a bunch of experts to
say
here let me show you let me gladly show
you here how i did it coming would you
be able to do that
of course i mean you know what chris
anderson he is the ones right the famous
paper who supports the nature origin as
a correspondent author and
first author that paper's name
is a proximal origin of south korea ii
which tell people that this is come from
nature
and with a lot of flaws in his theory
this was published in february and of
course hasta well who come
out to said this is never come from the
lab
but hey and if you check his twitter
he can turn off his comment when he
comment about this thing
i mean i'm the one suspended from
twitter i won't tell the truth to people
and i reply to people
who really read my report and ask
questions in researchgate
but why him as a expert
in this field face to these things turn
off his comment
don't allow people to open this cast
with him
and also the other professor like
someone mentioned that
is very clear things happened all around
and
of course this is not something
specifically
uh invented by chinese lab or by some
maps
but as i said this is something
like the knife in the next to the dead
person and very specific
here it means it's in that uh
that's just pervasive write that lineage
b as we clearly mentioned in the
sentence
in that type that group of viruses we
don't have this
uh cleavage site and we have another
figure beautiful figure next to that
explanation to tell people say so many
so many so many viruses
know this side but then you said in
other virus
why don't you talk about hypoma why
don't you talk about
influenza we know you learn from those
viruses and that's why later
after the ex understanding of that feral
cleavage site
it was purposely uh equipped
into this asteroid too to make it more
harmful
so i stress it clearly in my report but
these people don't allow me to talk
and they they just tell the things show
their
expert with the title in the journals
and media
and you if you check this kind of all
this kind of article
actually i have 26 pages these the
authors of those publications the people
who can do it who works with them who
are expert
who is good in this they called some old
technique
no that is classic traditional even this
year that technique is published by dr
difer
in the university of minnesota to show
how they swept
that's curvy to that part to sas
we cite that paper and those experts
using their position to mice to mislead
people who trust them
who cannot read the paper or who don't
have enough time to understand this
paper
and as still as i mentioned
first i have the support from the real
expert
in u.s government and also i had
feedback
from other scientists and researchers
who can understand this paper
and the third thing is like those people
i listed in the report who i
showed that they can do it and they did
it to come to argue with me
in a scientific way i i mean welcome
the life open debate but don't
let people tell in journals use the
similar comment as
oh this is not the academic institution
just because i have to escape
and i'm faced with my danger and also
drag to it to political
this is not political you guys make it
political this is about
global health about trees back to the
pandemic's
reason about how to solve it from the
beginning it should never happen from
the beginning
and also don't just use the same word
again and again said
all this is nonsense and this is
hilarious
and use the nice mislead please i have
this
so many many smoking guns don't just
drag little bit terms out and
use your eyes to chase people
that's my statement delivered to the
world
you know what when i published this
paper they said i don't go through peer
review because that
is the very uh hobby scientific way
to let people know this is a real
scientific paper
but how many scientific paper from
nature science
their mindset was withdrawn was found
out to be
fake data misinformation after peer
review
thousands and when i submit this to the
preprint website the bio ikea
which is a big one under the cold
spring harbor laboratory i submit
it in last sunday 7 pm eastern time
they said it usually takes 24 hours to
publish online because
this is no peer review basically just
checked the format
and the next morning ate from 8 a.m
to 9 30 the whole website
broke down we have evidence
who is scared of my article and even the
databases shut down
broke down the same database under the
laboratory the mad active and the camera
cave
are okay at that time but only the bio
arcade
get attacked or you may i
believe that is hacked we have evidence
that's why i have to
turn to zinado once we publish it from
the node
just after several minutes i told it on
twitter that i published it
cinada got somehow attacked
and broke down again so who is scared of
the report
i put myself to be responsible for the
things i state
and i welcome the fair life
argue open argue based on the scientific
evidence
about these things but why i get silence
and you say parker interview me
and takasu also get attacked gets
suppressed
and how could you let the other i mean
scientists and researchers come out
support me in public i mean someone
support me
but if you want them to go to media you
know they have to face through the
attack
is this is this something is this
something that if we
got the top 20 you guys all clash you
don't agree
you don't know what you're talking about
you're all these people all of you
together in the same room in a lab
how many days would it take for you to
be able to be able to prove
not papers in a lab how much time would
you need to be able to prove this as
man-made
uh to be clear you mean too much people
really understand like for example i
give a presentation
to explain it to the people in the lab
matters you can understand on our domain
dac
well how did you find out that this is
man-made didn't you go in the lab and go
through the virus and dissect the virus
to find out
i mean this is i already provided a way
you can reconstruct it in the map
did you reconstruct it in a lab the
first time you found out it's man-made
not by myself i give you the weight that
is available and using the traditional
way
it's convenient english which is listed
in the practical of my
report from this one it's like a recipe
and with every step i mean of course you
can argue the
little bit change because i'm not the
one who watched them doing this
for all the time in the woohoo
how long six months six months minimum
you don't have so
so look here's why i'm saying this look
for me
i'm skeptical about both sides okay and
i like being skeptical about both sides
because i don't have a hundred percent
data on both sides i don't know if it's
man-made i don't know if it's natural
i uh um i quite frankly don't trust both
sides 100
and i kind of want to hear it i want to
see all the people this is why we have
debates this is why we put biden and
trump in a room
on september 29th to debate and see what
we can believe and we get to choose
who we want as a president if secretary
of state mike pompeo is watching this
which i have a feeling they're going to
watch this i know bannon's going to
watch us and all those guys going to
watch it
my recommendation is why don't you guys
call
for all the skeptics to come in the same
room together including yourself
and hash it out and let us watch it let
us watch this debate
and one more thing very important you
know so
why don't these people i listed in the
report come out
they are the ones they feel offense that
if they feel this
is some mice and which humiliate them
or ruin their reputation they should
they should come out and go to that
debate with me face to me
i will comment i would like you to be
alive
youtube facebook twitter live let us all
judge for ourselves with the way people
react and how you guys go back and forth
because
i don't think this is one of those
things where uh uh
uh this is not who's a better rapper
this is not who the better basketball
player is because people's lives don't
are not on the line
million people have died because it is
nearly a million people have died
because of this
the way that the reports have come out
this is a very important matter the
world stopped for six months
trillions of dollars were lost because
if this is man-made
they need to be held accountable and if
you based on your research that you're
making you're not right
i think we also need to know that you
were wrong in certain places i think
that's what i want to know myself so but
let me go to a different angle here let
me go to a different angle here
lee wen liang okay this was a gentleman
a
optomologist who worked in wuhan central
hospital
on september 30th he sent a message to a
group of fellow doctors
warning them about a possible outbreak
of an illness that resembles severe
respiratory syndrome
sars in wuhan hubei province china where
he worked at
this was meant to be private he
encouraged them to protect themselves
from the infection days later he was
summoned to public security
bureau and wuhan made to sign a
statement in which he was accused of
making false statements
that disturbed the public order he died
on february 7
2020. did you get a chance to meet him
did you have a relationship with him
my friend knew him this is a small group
where the similar age the doctors and
the justice 31 december even before the
news come out i already heard about that
and also uh dr
levinder sings already getting known is
doctors in wuhan at that time so even
among our nice group when the doctor
from other cities to
confirm this the doctors in wuhan dare
not to say anything because government
don't allow them to talk about it
they just show the mask emoji people
know
shut up but wear mask this was shown in
the fox news that
documentary the 30 minutes when released
in
july so a follow-up to this question
here is
they say he died from coronavirus
there's a lot of conspiracies about him
are there any other stories you know
since a friend of yours was friends with
him
what do they how he died hey was
punished
by this as a of the mom of jester he was
sent
to do the first month to treat
patients and at that time as i said not
enough protection in wuhan
right and even later government didn't
give them enough protection
and also i can tell you even also
government now don't
meet and even push his family to keep
silent
but leaving their deaths is because of
the postpone of treatment
purposely from government postpone of
treatment from the government so they
didn't
need him and they wanted him so indirect
what you're saying is that was their way
of
executing him uh sorry
that is your interpretation that that's
their way of
making him die or not even letting him
die so if he can get the treatment
addressed
on time and things can be changed
okay all right yeah as a doctor i cannot
say a hundred percent or something but
you know
the treatment comments like that when
you make comments like that to me
i say you're reasonable you're not
emotional i ask it because i want to see
if you're going to give me an emotional
reaction and you didn't which means you
gained credibility to know that you're
not coming free from a place of anger
or you're not upset you're just trying
to get to the truth and i respect that
on may 2020 the fbi issued a statement
on a new investigation
china affiliated cyber actors have been
both targeting and compromising u.s
organization conducting covenanting
related research
these attacks aim to steal research
results related to vaccines treatments
and vaccines and according to wall
street journal u.s officials stated that
china and iran
started such attacks as early as january
3rd to try to get data from uh
america to see what they're doing
because they wanted to find out more
about covet
in in the in the space of china when
you're there
and you're living there you lived there
for 30 years
there is the media there's news on what
you watch on tv
and then there's real talk on how people
talk behind closed doors right
yes how are the people how do they
see china uh the media
the government the ccp how do majority
of people in china the populace behind
closed doors
see the government and the ccp i mean to
be honest the
the propaganda in china is quite
powerful
surveillance is quite strong and after
decades of decay spring wash there are
rarely
certain parts of chinese people are
brainwashed
and also that our chinese government won
that kind of education to people but
for the people who realize the society
i mean at home in private or tell them
maybe when they are talking to kids they
will tell you that
they complain the government and they
know for example in different
aspects like the you go to school
your face do the unfair things unfair
treatment
and you go to work for the promotion
for the competition there are different
unfair treatment
and also in the media we have to say
the false news like uh fake news for
example our
ministry of the diploma always tell that
u.s
spread virus to china it origins from
europe
u.s salmon and even outer space
people cannot say no in public but
deeply inside i mean the
smart people they know these are the
mice
the thing is they are scared of the
government
and also that's why there are not only
me there are some other people
also wake up and then dare to tell the
truth
through different ways like for example
all this media the broadcast
all donate to the rule of mouth
foundation to support people who are
fighting for this
fighting for the truth so so so that's
very interesting what you're saying that
so
do people in china have access to vpns
to uh uh to to get on facebook or
youtube
anybody in china have access to anywhere
outside because when i was speaking to
nomi prince who used to work at goldman
sachs
she told me she said when she would stay
at the rich or at the hotel
in the uh in the business center lobby
at the highest level they had access to
social media facebook
and news so if they did wouldn't there
be other
for the people of china to be able to
see and follow the news and u.s
workplaces
uh i mean using vpn right so vpn is not
safe for them
the government allows some vpn to be
used
between certain people for example
working in the foreign companies in
china
or the top people in the universities or
some like this
or some common people who buy vpn but
i can tell you first vpn is very
unstable in china
the vpn is easy to get ineffective
at any time and also once government
want to change your solution they did it
they can't do it and there are many
cases happen
in china that because they use vpn so
government even put them to prison
so this odyssey and another thing is
there
is a special military called cyber
military
online which is actually maintained by
by chinese communist
party and they recruit the prisoners
of the students or the common people and
just to do the propaganda things and
attack the truth against the chinese
communist party
and also target like me online so these
people
they need to go through vpn
yeah they need to go through vpn so okay
so here's another question for you i
interviewed you nami park
who was a defector from north korea she
went to uh
uh china then south korea then she came
over i heard about that you've heard
about her and she gave a talk you got 50
million views in a couple days
uh uh she said in north korea
they called americans american bastards
is what they call them what does the
media in china call americans
if you check the global time you check
the
uh cctv and you check the
ministry of diploma that their statement
i mean they call it like pompeo as
uh i i say how to translate all the
people's enemy
like this kind of work and they use the
myers
and even bad word to describe this
and also another thing i can tell you
that i'm not sure how many u.s people
know this
but our chinese government always try to
use
the people's unknown about u.s
to make them have some strong
emotion against the u.s government
for example during 9-1-1 time i was a
middle school
middle school student at that time when
9-1-1 happened
our government put it on news
and allow the students to watch it and
encourage people to applaud
for that because it happened in u.s
so they encourage this kind of things
although
at that time we are young i mean i'm
sure i'm not the only one who feel
uncomfortable
for this situation but we cannot speak
it out because
we are still young and the teachers and
the government
they won't lead you to that
you know opposite side to show that this
is something happening in u.s and
because they are our
you know enemy or not friend i mean this
is very bad i don't
want to harm u.s people speeding and i
won't stress
with chinese people are announcing
because this is a government
need propaganda even you
won't be against that you cannot speak
out because you will be kept to silence
immediately
here's another question for you uh who
on media does
china paint as good people like you know
if we're in us you'll see the media you
know
they'll say they're friendly with israel
they'll say they're friendly with
you know certain countries that have
good relationships with and you'll see
it from media you'll see it from the
government you'll see it from the
politicians
pretty consistent that we have good
relations with certain nations
what countries do china does china paint
the media
as being friendly like what does china
say about iran and north korea
i think they call them the good friends
right
because we say it in iran yeah our good
friend i mean from the
code as a government good friend
north korea always good friend and this
you can verify from the news and if you
need
uh i think there are many people can
translate it
from chinese to english and provide the
material to because
it's in public they are our traditional
friends
anybody else that's your traditional
friend of china like iran north korea
any other countries or no
sorry that are considered good friends
like iran and
north korea i think they sometimes have
some other good friend
and it's just after the situation
whether they collaborate with them
sometimes you as a friend too you as a
friend
when they are making the deals
that makes sense again you say things
like that it gives you more credibility
because you sound
reasonable when you're saying what
you're saying you know
the other part i want to bring up is
you've been talking about the fact that
you know uh uh um you know you're not
safe you don't feel safe so you can't
disclose while you're at because you
know china may be coming after you and
even this interview we're not conducting
on zoom the interview is being done on a
completely different platform for
you to feel safe which we accommodated
of course we would accommodate that
but why do you not feel uh safe for your
life like what can china really do to
you you're in america how could they
hurt you
uh to have many ways to do it i am under
protection
now and what i can tell you is for
example
my iphone the one i was using in china
compact motor and i bring to the us and
even fbi hold it for several days for
the evidence
that forward hacked and uh during
june when the fox news gave the
exclusive shot
with me for four hours and at last they
said oh we won't check the
some evidence on your phone i said okay
just hide the
my friend's identity and i show the
phone to them
i remind them be careful chairman she
may smile to you through my phone and
they
asked ah funny and one day
i switched on my phone and there is no
internet
no sim card inside once i switch it
i switch the wii chat on their camera
detects the
infrared but no infrared
from my iphone and they are scared the
host and the
stuff is what happened and i lost my
lawyer i said i told you they hacked it
right
and also like in the beer hammer show i
got the live
interview in the unknown location
i tried my best i mean you can see the
almost like here only the wall behind me
but somehow the chinese cyber military
people
those agents analyzed my
that video and locate it and post online
to street me said we know you have
locations here
sometimes they do the wrong analysis
like where i get the fox news interview
they said somewhere else but they
already did it wrong
but that means these people always focus
on me
and i have to move from manhattan to now
this is new place
because that place is exposed
i cannot tell you the specific things i
don't want
tell me your location yeah all these
things no i don't want you to tell me
your location
what i am asking you is so what if they
know where you're at what are they going
to do to you i mean you're in america
you know they're not here you are in
america yeah but you say i
am the witness in the whole pandemic
from the early beginning
and i'm the scientist and the doctor
i can explain the things to people in a
reasonable scientific way
combined with intelligence and other
things
and also i'm the one who did it from
mid-january
which was the first one in the world
they cannot deny
now they try to say i'm the one just
come out after half a year
so i collect information online no we
have the broadcast online recorded the
time and the thing i was told
i told people right so this all together
and
with the evidence i have they know
if i am silent i despaired
it's very very difficult for us people
and for government to find another one
to tell the truth and that will help
chinese communist party a lot uh are you
currently in communication with anybody
in china have you some of you
reached out to you know my family i shut
down the
and cut off all the connection makes
sense
has the trump administration at all
reached out to you to offer protection
some senior people from the government
what i can tell you including the expert
they talk to me some of them have
yeah some of them already have done that
and also they read my
report even before i publish it so
that's why
the question about peer review work
before you published it
yeah okay totally convinced that that's
why
when i get a text file that you don't
have peer reviewed
no it's okay i just think this is an
urgent thing
and in case the other power try to
manipulate
or reject it or hide it i want to show a
peer review to the world
to anyone as a peer review
if if you are uh uh if you're
if your sources are that accurate of
what you're saying
and if i'm on the trump administration
and i'm watching this
i would want to protect you i wouldn't
want to leave you where you are i would
need to offer protection at the highest
level to bring you in in case
god forbid something were to happen in
case god forbid something were to happen
because
if what you say is true
this could be the biggest cover-up of
this century
yes if what you say is true
it could take decades
generations for china to regain trust
from other nations
if what you say is true and it's a big
if and i'm hoping the people on this
side
from national geographic that's owned by
disney i'm hoping
daily beast i'm hoping these doctors
rasmussen's i'm hoping all of these
folks that are calling you out
i'm hoping they agree to do a um
debate or even sit down where we can
kind of uh make a decision for ourselves
on uh what's going on over here so you
know before i wrap up the interview i
want to give you the floor
and give you the final words assume at
this point
uh uh this video stays up hopefully
youtube sees this as a fair interview
and they keep it up they're pretty good
to us
assume this video stays up and many
people have watched this
what would you like to leave the viewer
the viewer could be
folks in the white house the viewer
could be average day-to-day people that
want to be educated
the viewer could be a couple of these
doctors that called you out the viewer
could be
uh many of the media platform that are
going to write negative reviews about
this article and they're going to
contact me to want to write the paper
because this has happened or passed
before
what would you like to say to people
okay
the first thing is i want to tell the
audience that
i do ate just because i'm the doctor
i'm the scientist when i say the truth
when i know the truth
i know that is urgent for the global
health
it's not for me for myself and not for
my
family it is for everyone i mean
everyone
deserves the truth everyone has to
protect yourself
protect your family and we should get
void
of such pandemic soon and the only way
to solve this one
is to understand why it happened
how it happened who did it
and then go back to the fundamental
beginning
it's like the doctor treats the patient
if you don't know why he gets an
infection you don't know the pathogen
and this may come back again and again
become
recurrent we should not amount these
things happen
in the future we have to protect our
next generation protect
the people who we love so
everyone can go to the noddle i'll go to
my research get the academic profile or
go to some other database where people
share this report there this
is for free open access only 26 pages
please this is related to yourself read
it
learn eight you will know what i said
and i will show the next report together
as
chinese communist party and who claimed
that we need a scientific evidence these
are the scientific evidence
what i do is not because of the
reputation or any other benefits
just too much you know the truth you can
go to verify by yourself but don't just
mislead
by some report go to check the report
by yourself and you will know the truth
thank you dr liam uh menyan thank you so
much for your time we're going to put
the link to the research below
for people to go read for themselves i
had a chance to read the whole 26 pages
myself
i highly recommend for the viewer if
you're watching this if it's up i highly
recommend you share this text
tweet it facebook it share it on uh uh
instagram wherever it may be for
a conversation to get started the
biggest thing for me is to start the
dialogue and uh hopefully this can lead
to
us getting to the truth whatever the
truth maybe that's all i'm interested in
i want to know what's really going on
over here again thank you so much for
your time
thank you for agreeing to this exclusive
a long form interview i believe this is
the longest
interview you've done i appreciate you
being uh willing to have the courage to
come on and be guest on valuetainment
thank you very much and i thank you for
all your effort to spreading this fact
to the people
thank you thank you i'm curious do you
believe her
do you believe her story do you believe
what she's saying
is true is it man-made is it not i mean
you saw some areas where she got pushed
a couple things that makes me think
about it is number one she didn't tell
me to not ask her anything like she
didn't say
you can interview me but you can't ask
me xyz obviously i didn't ask about
family but
she didn't say you can't ask me about
anything you know what i mean so in
certain ways you're watching it to see
if she's telling the truth or not i'd
love to see all those guys come together
and hash it out and debate because this
is a international matter
it's a foreign matter it's something
that the world was affected by but do
you believe her
comment below and by the way if you
enjoyed her interview i also did an
interview with johan me park
who was another defector who escaped
north uh north korea and she went to
china and then south korea and
eventually ended up being here
and she gave a message i believe at 13
14 years old that the video got 50
million views in two days
when she gave her talk about what her
experience was like escape in north
korea but
there's a lot we're learning about you
know north korea south korea and china
and
if you've not seen that interview click
over here and watch that interview if
you're not subscribed to the channel
please do so as well
thank you for watching everybody take
care bye
[Music]
you